the jurgen experience that narcos is
interesting they did
they did them right i think this year
they're going to miami they killed it
with pablo
they killed it killed it killed that guy
so good killed it
and the guy the guy i like that they
hired was that dude that got like 2 000
years in jail
the one who ran the island like his
story is
hilarious because he was uh
a john lennon fanatic yeah and
he was half german so he was a hitler
but he was spanish okay and he was
it sounds like a saturday livestream so
when the cops
went when the feds went all uh
extradite on these guys they became the
extraditables
this guy took to the radio and they show
scenes of him
on the radio [ __ ] ah like
okay so you cannot take us back to the
united states
because you're the number one exporter
of our product and he's snowing awesome
he sees like an assistant walk by he
goes hey
come here and all of a sudden he's like
and listen she just kneels down
she's blowing him on camera and he's and
he's like
listen to me you have to he became nuts
when was this listen listen to what they
did okay hold on is there a video this
you can get
oh my god carlos laid there is
a [ __ ] lunatic carlos laid there
was the one who went to pablo
and said i'm gonna i'm gonna fly the
coke back for you
but we're gonna make a stop on an island
so they bought an island
they [ __ ] threw the doctor off there
was a white doctor
nice to meet you and they were like
listen
there's a whole story about it that's
hysterical the guy called the feds
there's something going on over there
they're doing pornographic
you know they're running in planes of
blow wow and this is one they bought
everybody out but there was this one
white dude who's like this is my island
i'm an american i fought in world war ii
i'm not leaving and they're like dawg
we're gonna [ __ ] kill you okay we're
gonna keep
and all night they were bringing in
planes refueling them
and sending them out carlos laid there
what does it say u.s drug lord and
escobar partner laid there
released for in germany from prison when
was this oh my god he's
just now from florida to germany oh from
florida to germany
because he's originally from germany
he's his father was german
he's got 2 000 years so what they did
was this
what they did was this it doesn't take a
[ __ ] genius
this kid got the island he made them a
bunch of money
but then he started doing a podcast from
the island
with cameras and naked women what of him
snorting coke with a robot how old was
he
who the [ __ ] knows 28 30 just making
20 million a day i think if you're
making 20 million a day
and you're just addicted to coke there's
bags of blow behind you
he's just ripping bags open snorting
them just talking he was a john lennon
fan
so he would talk about coming today is
he would do these videos for hours for
days
so he was like an original youtube star
yeah so what they did was but he wasn't
posting on youtube
he was like
he's the first one they gave up when the
[ __ ] got deep
and the colombians were in trouble the
five colombians sat down they said
listen
this kid's on an island talking about
jim morrison in the doors
let's let them let's let the feds know
where he's at
we'll give him you and we got no beef
so they actually died and laid there
they gave him
2 000 years oh my god look up the
sentence i'm not trying to be funny
they gave him a thousand so why would
they extradite him to germany because he
gave them information years later about
he gave them he gave them like vital he
gave them
really great information that if the
country [ __ ] knew
we would sink like he gave him [ __ ] what
he gave them information that he was he
also not
beside having his island that that was
also
a a distraction
his main contributor his main supplier
was fidel
so he fidel was letting him go to cuba
bring the coke to cuba stock it and for
every ship that went out from cuba to
the united states
with a cuban flag fidel would get a
kickback of 800 thousand dollars
fidel was sending three four ships a day
so he testified against fidel which
obviously nobody ever arrested fidel and
he told him everything he knew about the
ins and outs of money moving
you could find it online all the [ __ ] he
had done
isn't it funny like no one wants their
son to do that
but everybody loves these movies
[Applause]